in this video we're going to talk about
one of the most common types of curves
you will see in mathematics and that is
the parabola and the word parabola
sounds quite fancy but we'll see it's
describing something that is fairly
straightforward now in terms of why it
is called the parabola I've seen
multiple explanations for it it comes
from Greek para that root word similar
to parable you could view of something
beside alongside something in parallel
bola same root as when we're talking
about ballistics throwing something so
you could interpret it as beside
alongside something that is being thrown
now how does that relate to curves like
this well my brain immediately imagines
well this is the trajectory this is the
path that is a pretty good approximation
for the path of things that are actually
thrown when you study physics you will
see the path you'll approximate the
paths of objects being thrown as
parabolas so maybe that's where it comes
from but there are other potential
explanations for why it is actually
called the parabola it has been lost to
history but what exactly is a parabola
in future videos we're going to describe
it a little bit more algebraically and
this one we just want to get a sense for
what parabolas look like and introduce
ourselves to some terminology
terminology around a parabola so these
three curves they are all hand-drawn
versions of a parabola and so you
immediately notice some interesting
things about them some of them are open
upwards like this yellow one and this
pink one and some of them are open
downwards and you will hear people say
things like open open down open
downwards or open down or open upwards
so it's good to know what they're
talking about and it's hopefully fairly
self-explanatory open upwards the the
parabola parabola is open towards the
top of our graph paper here it's open
towards the bottom of our graph paper
this is looks like a right-side up view
this looks like an upside down
right over here this pink one would be
open upwards now another term that
you'll see associated with a parabola
and once again in the future we'll learn
how to calculate these things and find
them precisely is the vertex and the
vertex you should view as the maximum or
minimum point on a parabola so if a
parabola opens upwards like these two on
the right the vertex is the minimum
point the vertex is the minimum point
right over there and so someone said
what is the vertex of this yellow
parabola well it looks like the X looks
like the x-coordinate is three and a
half so it is three and a half and looks
like the y coordinate it looks like it
is about negative three and a half and
once again once we start representing
these things with the equations we'll
have techniques for calculating them
more precisely but the vertex of this
other upward-opening parabola it is the
minimum point it is the low point there
is no maximum point on an upward-opening
parabola it just keeps increasing as X
gets larger in the positive or the
negative direction now if your parabola
opens downward then your vertex is going
to be your maximum point now related to
the idea of a vertex is the idea of an
axis of symmetry and in general when
we're talking about well not just three
them two dimensions but even three
dimensions but especially in two
dimensions you can imagine a line over
which you can flip the you can flip the
graph and so it meets it folds on to
itself and so the axis of symmetry for
this yellow graph right over here for
this yellow parabola it would be this
line it could draw it a little bit
better it would be it would be that line
right over there you could fold the
parabola over that line and it would
meet itself and that line I didn't draw
it as neat as I should that should go
directly through the vertex so to
describe that line you would say that
line is X is equal to three point five
similarly the axis of symmetry for this
pink
it should go through the line x equals a
negative one so let me do that
that's the axis of symmetry it goes
through the vertex and if you were to
fold the parabola over it would meet
itself the axis of symmetry for this
green one it should once again go
through the vertex it looks like it is X
is equal to negative six this is let me
write that down that is the axis of
symmetry
now another concept that isn't unique to
parabolas but we'll talk a lot about it
in the context of parabolas are
intercepts so when people say
y-intercept and you saw this when you
first graph lines they're saying where
does the graph where does the curve
intercept or intersect the y-axis so the
y-intercept of this yellow line would be
right there it looks like it's the point
0 comma 3 0 comma 3 the y-intercept for
the pink one is right over there we at
least on this graph paper we don't see
the y-intercept but eventually will
intersect the y-axis it just will be way
off of this screen now you might also be
familiar with the term x-intercept and
that's especially interesting with
parabolas as we'll see in the future
x-intercept is where you intercept or
intersect the x axis and here this
yellow one you see it does it two places
and this is where it gets interesting
lines will only intersect the x axis
once but at most but here we see that a
parabola can intersect the x axis twice
because it curves back around to
intersect it again and so for here the
x-intercepts are going to be the point 1
comma 0 and 6 comma 0 now you might
already notice something interesting the
x-intercepts are symmetric around the
axis of symmetry so they should be equal
distant from that axis of symmetry and
you can see they indeed are they're both
exactly 2 and 1/2 away from that axis of
symmetry and so if you know where the
intercepts are you just take you could
say the midpoint
of the x-coordinates and then you're
going to have the axis of symmetry the
x-coordinate of the axis of symmetry and
the x-coordinate of the actual vertex
similarly the x-intercept here looks
like it's negative the points are
negative seven comma zero and negative
five comma zero and the x coordinate of
the vertex or the line of symmetry is
right in between those two points now
it's worth noting not every parabola is
going to intersect the x axis notice
this pink upward-opening parabola it's
low point is above the x axis so it's
never going to intersect the actual x
axis so this is actually not going to
have any x-intercepts so I'll leave you
there those are actually the core ideas
or the core visual themes around
parabolas and we're going to discuss
them in a lot more detail when we
represent them with equations and as
you'll see these equations are going to
involve second degree terms so the most
simple parabola is going to be y is
equal to x squared but then you can
complicate it a little bit you could
have things like Y is equal to 2x
squared minus 5x plus 7 these types and
we'll talk about in more general terms
these types of equations sometimes
called quadratics and they are
represented generally by parabolas